hello everyone we have successfully
completed our 1970 palma de mallorca
intra zonal tournament where Bobby
Fischer completely obliterated the field
now we entered in 1971 candidates
matches its marked amount of versus
Bobby Fischer in in round one so a
couple of months have passed since the
palma de america in turn zonal now we
are in Vancouver Canada where this
matches matches taking place and luckily
for us we have Michael Tao entertaining
this games for a magazine that he was
the I believe the chief editor in the
Shock magazine 64 but before we check
out the game we do have a nice photo
challenge so best of luck to everyone
it's a rather and older for all these
gentlemen but I'm pretty sure all of you
will know who they are so there we have
it
who are the two world champions in this
photo I believe that's hint enough so
like I said best of luck to everyone now
let's talk about this matchup for a bit
now before this match even started
Fisher and diamond off played two games
so far one in the Buenos Aires
tournament of 1960 and that game was a
draw and the other you've seen on my
channel a couple of days ago we covered
the game from the 1970 form of the
America inter-zonal tournament that
Bobby Fischer won so so far 1 and 1/2 to
have in Fischer's favor and the day will
now play a match of 10 games so very
interesting and as far as tall is
concerned tall says that there is no
favorite in this matchup it it all
depends what what kind of games they
will play if they will play like really
simple games where you know you have to
go in a in an end game and playing and
game for like 5 hours then of course
Fischer will be the favorite as tall
says that Fischer that tall basically
says that they only have one player like
Fischer in in the Soviet Union and that
is Viktor Korchnoi
that question is the only player that
can play an equal end game for five
hours and and still try to win that game
because he is truly an NN game expert
and he doesn't think that tomorrow
should really go into any long longer
end games against Bobby and also he
thinks that
tomorrow should really brush up on some
of his opening records especially if he
if he is planning to play in the
Sicilian against Bobby Fischer as tall
considers Fischer to be one of the
strongest players against the Sicilian
so if you want to face Bobby with the
Sicilian you really have to prepare so a
lot of the things to consider here but
he doesn't consider Fischer the favorite
here he says it all depends on how the
games go so this is a game number one of
their match let's see how the game went
in in the game number one tamaño has the
white pieces and he opens with d4 we do
even we already had this photo but just
quickly here is a photo of this of this
game there's taimanov on the right with
the white pieces Fischer on the left
with the black pieces everything is all
set and ready in Vancouver Canada here
we have a nice photo of two of them
playing it's a photo of some other game
as here Fischer has the white pieces and
also here we have a very nice close-up
of tomorrow so that all that being said
not like to check out this game we have
nice to have six c4 g6 Knight to c3 and
Bishop to g7 here Fischer opts for the
Kings Indian defense we have E for d6
Knight to f3 Fisher castles Bishop to e2
and now II five we have castles Knight
to c6 d5 Thurmond of advances the pawn
in the central grab some more space
Knight to e7 and here at all says that
in his previous games taimanov was known
to play nights to e1
b4 was also played in some of his games
he played nice the d2 but for this game
he prepared Bishop to d2 - you know just
in case Fischer prepared for everything
at amount of place he wanted to play
something new new in this game Fischer
goes 498 that prepares the advance of
the F pawn we have roped the c1 and now
F file of course he captures on f5g
captures on f5 and now Knight to g5 here
tal says that this is a well known plan
it's it's really a you know it creates a
very dynamic position crazy positions
will arise out of this plan our white
once black to attack this night and then
white wants to bring his night over to
e6 and here black will be forced to give
up the light square bishop and then at
this point when it advances to e6 it
will become a weak bond and black will
be able to capture it but in the
meantime while black has occupied
capturing this pawn a white will be able
to organize an attack or at least white
should be able to so h6 attacking the
knight we have 96 all is as planned
Bishop captures pawn captures and now
Queen to c8 Fischer is ready to not to
not capture this pawn and now Queen to
b3 the standard idea of course now if
you capture here then Queen capture some
b7 is coming and black it didn't really
gain anything he just gave up the bishop
air for nothing
white grab the pawn here and all this
wall so instead after Queen to b3 first
a Fischer plays c6 now Fischer's plan is
nice to see 7 and here he wants to grab
this pawn on e6 with the night while the
Queen is guarding the b7 pawn tamaño
goes for Bishop to h5 also tal mentions
because it is tall the idea of Knight to
d5 not really working working out for
white because after you capture capture
okay you open up a nice attack against
the Queen here I'm but after Queen goes
to b8 you can go
Queen to h3 create a nice attack against
the h6 pawn here but after rook to f6
the pawn is nicely guarded and here you
can push something like f4 but this is I
mean white is a clear piece up a black
is a clear piece up and there is no
immediate compensation so perhaps you
could play something like this in a
blitz game or like if you're extremely
motivated or creative but it you know
all in all it should not work so here
after c6 the amount of went for Bishop
to h5 his idea is that if Fischer
continues with his plan of night to c7
and going after this pawn he can simply
protect it with the bishop to f7 check
and then after King goes to h7 now the
pawn is guarded and now if the Knight
captures the
or it seems that all should be okay but
style actually prefers this tosses that
this should be better for black then
what's Fischer played for example if
rook F to be one then Knight captures
Bishop captures Queen captures and now
after Queen captures here now rook to b8
and after Queen captures here
rook capture some b2 and tal says that
this is this is very nice for black and
that he prefers this to what Fischer
played but here after Bishop to h5 as
Fischer does enjoy being up in material
he goes for Queen captures on e6
immediately we have Queen captures on b7
and the not Knight to f6 now attacking
the bishop on h5 bishop goes back and
now we have rook F to b8 attacking the
Queen Queen to a6 and now rook capture
some b2 rook F to D 1 and now the
immediate efore and here tamaño vis down
upon but he has a lot of activity and he
does have a lot of good options here for
example he could go for something like
Bishop to f4 but then after night comes
to g6 attacking the bishop you have to
play something like rook captures on b6
and after Queen to e7 there's not not
really all that you can do here and now
your Bishop is under attack your rook is
under attack and if you move the bishop
back you're gonna get f4 and you're
gonna lose a piece here since you have
to move your rook it's no longer
defended so after this Knight to g6 you
can't really capture here with the rook
you could capture with the bishop but
not not really so definitely not in the
greatest of plants this Bishop to f4 so
taimanov goes for Queen to a3 he attacks
Fischer's rook on b2 we have looked at
b7 and now comes a bishop to f4 here d5
as it is it is a forced move see captors
on d5c captors and e5 and now Knight the
b5 here a Fisher plays Knight to g6 and
here we have the critical the critical
moment of the game were taimanov has so
many options but what which is the
correct one for example night to c7 does
seem very interesting attacking the
Queen and the rook what happens if this
is played for example if night c7 then
you get Queen to f7
and now you have to see that after you
capture the rook and we have night
captures on f4 how do you get the knight
out of the corner how do you get the
knight out of a a8
for example Bishop to e6 it's a nice
move but you know you have to find it
before you actually decide to go for
this variation now
now comes the main plan you have to see
that rook to b8 it does not work for
black to attack the knight because now
you get a queen here attacking the rook
but also the knight on f4 and I were to
route capture screen captures and now
white is up what is up the exchange and
clearly in a better position so here
after this Bishop to a six of course the
rook to b8 it does not work you have to
play rook the d7 then come to Bishop to
b5 attacking the rook then you move up
the d8 attacking the knight and now
Knight to c7 and the knight is now out
of the corner but a lot of moves to see
and you know it's not easy to decide for
something like this
another thing you can do to protect this
guy here is Queen to g3 but Queen to g3
against this Fischer had a very nice
tactical shot here his plan was
Knight to h5 now the Queen and the
bishop is under attack if you don't want
to lose your piece you have to capture
the night here and this was Fisher's
idea Knight captures an f4 Queen
captures an f4 and now rook captures on
b5 as the bishop is no longer guarding
the b v square and after rook to c7
where time honor would threaten Bishop
to f7 to win Fischer's Queen simply
Queen to e5 Queen captures Bishop
captures and here Fischer would yet
again keep his extra pawn advantage and
be able to push for a win here so really
really a crazy position after this
Knight to g6 move attacking Temenos
Bishop here so in this position the
amount of plate Knights the d4 he
attacked Fischer's Queen Fischer played
Queen to d7 and now comes Queen to e3 in
defending the bishop from e3 came to h7
by Fischer and now h3i useful move you
always want to create some breathing
room for the King also perhaps making a
room for the bishop on h2
rook to f8 and the now comes up to a six
and here you'll see just how far
both of them have calculated now
tomorrow is forcing Fisher's work to
move to move away from b7 this rook is
then coming to c7 which Fisher had a
Fisher has everything worked out we have
worked to be 6 and now rook the c7
attacking fierce Queen Fisher plays
Queen to a 4 a very nice move as it
comes into play would with an attack
against the rook and this was the amount
of plan rook captures on g7 with the
check so nice exchange sacrifice King
captures and now Bishop captures on h6
with check King to f7 and now of course
you cannot capture on f8 because first
Fisher will grab the rock and be one
with check so instead we have Bishop
back to e2 getting the better part of
the way so it's no longer attacked and
also defending the rook
so all seems to be what for white here
here Fisher goes rook F to b8 that was
up rooks and E and the B file and gets
his rock out of harm's way
Knight captures an f5 a very nice move
this was all still a part of tomorrow's
calculations now he's still down the
exchange but his attack is looking very
nice and Michael Tao agrees with Temenos
play rock the b1 and here even more
critical moment in the game it's always
funny when I say like that because
usually everyone always presents one
critical moment in the game but I don't
know okay maybe I should call other
critical moments something else but this
is an even more critical moment
regardless of the terminology here
tosses that here comes the first first
bad move by time on of in this game he
plays rook captures and b1 but he
doesn't have to react to this it's true
that the rook is attacked twice but
white can simply react here by improving
the position of the king king h2 and now
you have to realize that the rook cannot
be captured for example if rook captures
Bishop captures with an attack on the
Queen and now if Queen captures Queen
captures on a7 which check and the rook
is under attack
after King moves and now comes Knight to
g7 first not allowing the King to
capture the knight King moves and now
Queen captures rook with check and after
King before
we have Queen b6 check King moves and
after Bishop to e3 whatever black plays
whatever black plays black is getting
checkmated for example when a one Queen
b8 will be checkmate you can see that
the bishop is guarding this square
Knight is guarding these lights were
very nicely on the Queen is slicing all
the way here so a very nice idea but
atamanov perhaps short on time does not
find King to h2 rather he captures we
have rook captures and now comes King to
h2 okay
Fischer goes Queen to d7 attacking
Temenos night on f5 and here the second
not the greatest move by time on over he
is here he simply should have continued
with the G for keeping the knight on f5
as the knight on f5 is a beautiful
beautiful piece perhaps he was afraid of
d4 or something as I mean it was a
perhaps he was in time trouble but if he
ever pushes d4 or even something like
that then Bishop the c4 check will win
the game immediately King e8 and now
Queen here it's all over the bishops are
slicing go all the way here
the queen is threatening to capture on
f6 on g6 there's there's nothing to do
here but okay
he played night to d4 he got the knight
out of the way he didn't want to open up
his scheme too much and now it's Fischer
who will be yeah who will enjoy his
advantage here
Queen to d6 check by Fischer g3 and the
now comes Queen to b4 here Fischer is
threatening Queen to e 1 followed by
Queen to G 1 or 8 h1 with checkmate so
at the amount of attempts to prevent
this by playing Knight to c6 which is
another nice idea and now if Queen to e1
not a man off has a queen captures on a
7 with check and here he could easily
draw the game or or even win it but you
know he can't he can never lose it after
you know even if Fischer prevents some
of the checks the King is wide open here
the man off would be able to really
check Fischer's King and he does have
the bishop pair so if Fischer plays a
bad move it perhaps even checkmate him
but ok after Knight to c6 Fischer
doesn't go for it he goes
to be six offers a trade of Queens and
now of course you cannot trade Queens
here if you capture capture then
Fisher's up the exchange it would be an
easily winning position for Bobby
so instead after Queen to b6 we have
Knight captures on a7 trying to grab
upon here but it doesn't work here a
Fisher simply plays Queen captures on e3
we have Bishop captures on e3 and here
comes here comes a move atamanov missed
or otherwise you would never have gone
for this
I feel free to pause the video here and
win game number one in this historic
match for Bobby against Mark Damon of
Mark if again in which time out of to be
more precise I will give it a couple of
seconds if you wanna you know decide
whether to do it or not for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you have just won a very important game
of the this historic match and for those
of you who just wanna enjoy the show
the move is rook to e1 Fischer played
this move this is move 40 and here the
game was adjourned so you know when the
game was supposed to be resumed tamaño
decided not to continue this game as
after analyzing it at home he saw that
whatever he plays simply loses what if
you resign well whatever you playing you
obviously have to move the light square
bishop it's under attack it doesn't
really matter where you put it for
example there should be five now Knight
to e5 is coming
so here the threat of course is if you
play something like h4 d 4 is coming
after you capture Knight of 3 check
black wins a piece here but even if you
play something like King to g2 to avoid
this still you get nice to f3 d4 is
coming and now whatever white plays
there's really no useful move for white
here for example but should pass one d4
is coming you move the bishop now comes
Knight d5 threatening to capture the
dark square bishop and then push the D
pawn but whatever white place doesn't
really matter and I'd be 5 you simply
capture capture and bring the King in
and if white tries something like
pushing the pawn then you start pushing
your pawn and now it's all over there is
no defense against this and this you you
can either give up a bishop and then
lose the game or give up the night after
the point is pushed all the way to d1
but a wonderful game and yeah after this
Bishop to e3 first replayed roughly one
the game was adjourned and then marked a
man of resign the game without even
continuing here so that's game number
one of the 1971 candidates match marked
a man of vs Robert James Fisher I do
hope you enjoyed it and that you're
enjoying the coverage of the disembody
Fisher series so far I would like to
thank Albert where's Adrian della Rossa
and Tages Murata for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank all for watching and I
will see you soon with a game number two
and a couple of nice nice you know
sentences by Michael Tao himself about
this match and a game number two thank
you and I'll see you soon